you need to accept the fact that things
would break things would change
and you're willing and accepting and
you'll embrace it and you'll build
better out of it and i think if you have
people that share the same mindset then
you can really make big things together
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctec
hello and welcome to another awesome
episode of 20 minute leaders this
episode really is awesome trust me it's
with yuval mcgee the chief operating
officer of connect team where we're
talking about the way that the world is
changing and through digitalization
and 80 percent of the workforce is
fundamentally changing the way that they
interact with their employers and the
world around them meet you val the ceo
of connect team he joined connect team
in 2018 as the company's eighth employee
he studied a bachelor's of arts at
multidisciplinary studies at the
university of haifa and is a graduate of
the israeli naval academy prior to
connecting he led different business
partnerships and go to market
initiatives at windward a leading
maritime analytics company and served in
various leadership roles in the israeli
navy
fun fact he tried to be connecting's
first investor in the early days he used
to be flatmates with yuval and yuval and
amir yuval's the ceo and amir as the ceo
they used to be flatmates and amir
wouldn't let you all invest in the
company as they were too close to
friends and considering the way that the
company is today um probably would have
been a good idea to invest really
awesome episode thank you you've all for
joining me and enjoy
the chief operating officer at connect
team such a cool company growing
blazing
fast speed i know it firsthand because
as we just talked about before we
started
we were sharing a similar co-working
space until i was sort of kicked out
because you grew too much
and and took over the whole place
and i
couldn't even realize what was happening
so it just it's coming from a place of
of a lot of respect and
and honor so
congratulations it's not universal
nothing personal i love it um yuval you
know you're looking at sort of this
employee management
this non-desk employees all-in-one
company app what is it with employees
that you're you guys are so obsessed
about what's happening here
that this is an interesting space for
you
well i think it's a really really good
question um and maybe to address that we
need to start by better understanding
our audience
so when you think about our our
customers
they're pretty much everywhere it's all
those people that are not in front of a
desk
many times they don't even have emails
all the tools that you and i are used to
things like the microsoft office package
emails
slack other things are not available for
this type of audience
think about bus drivers about sellers in
retail stores about cleaners about
security guards this type of audience
comprise about 80 percent of the market
wow at the end when you take a company
like microsoft you know they sell to 30
of the market the other part of the the
globe is underserved
and this is where
connecting comes into the picture
our vision is basically to bring
everything employer and employee needs
under one roof it's an employee
management app
can offer pretty much everything they
need from day-to-day communication to
things that are related to operation
such as time tracking scheduling digital
forms things like that
and a lot of things around the hr front
um so training of employees document
management recognition different tokens
so you can incentivize them etc etc
so now that we understand the audience
to kind of address your question i think
one of our biggest vision is to do
something impactful for that part of the
audience that is underserved and to help
them come to the 21st century
in the sense that you know they can have
the same tools and same thing that
they're used to from their day-to-day
life in their work environment
interesting what how did the world look
like before so sort of what was the
world that we were living in
that that was not i guess trivial or
suitable
have you seen stranger things so pretty
much the same uh like things were in the
80s we're talking bulletin boards we're
talking funneling down communication
uh via face to face um
in today's world maybe they're using
whatsapp and you know they're sending it
to their managers we're actually selling
this to their managers which are
funneling it down
i think it's a to connect to that you
know it's there's an interesting story
about how connecting was born so our mir
our ceo and co-founder was talking to a
lot of like c-level
people from different industries at the
time it wasn't yet connected was mobile
lesson connecting is a pivot that was
born out of mobile lesson
um so amir met with a lot of different
executives many of them in the high-tech
domain um and you know we saw at the
time we were providing um an lms
uh learning management solution
a big part of it was on mobile which was
kind of new and then it came to a really
big chain of food and beverage with like
100 branches and about a thousand
employees
and was explaining to the ceo how he'll
be able to teach the people at less time
and they'll they'll be more attuned to
customer service et cetera et cetera
and then that's you'll just ask him but
will i be able to know how many
employees i have at every single moment
and amir takes a step back and he's like
you don't know how many employees you
have
he's like right three
for things to funnel down from the
branches to me
the holiday season is coming i need to
be 30
uh higher on the manpower side of things
and i have no idea to know if that's
happening or not and that's kind of when
things flicked when we understand how
much back
this type of audience is
um when it comes to managing their
workforce to understand what's going on
in the workforce
to name another really cool example that
i heard it and kind of really captured
my attention was um a very famous and
big chain
that provides beauty products
one and two knife employees were showing
up on time to the stores because if they
don't show up on time
uh the venue you know the big malls they
can charge you for not opening the store
on time so what they would have done
they would look at the cctv at the
actual camera screens to see that the
store opens up on time
and you know it just it's so
old-fashioned it's so silly to try and
run such a big operation that way
that we really understood that there is
a core need to make things different
and it's not a nice to have it's an
urgency it's a real core need to run
your business in a more efficient way to
bring it to what we know from our own
desk-based
workspaces so just to make sure that i'm
that i fully understand sort of where
what you know sort of the transition
here it sounds like that before the way
that organizations would manage their
sort of human resources in human capital
it would be through sort of these
mid-level managers that would be
reporting and would be consolidating
this information and trickling it down
or up back to sort of the management but
now you're saying if we're able to have
direct communication with
the frontline employees
and sort of sort of on a direct consumer
model we're able to get real-time
information pass information without
having to bypass through the mid-level
management and therefore we have much
more transparency and that has many
implications on different verticals and
you mentioned one which would be sort of
even the the shopping malls which i had
no idea that's how that's how it was
working right
yeah yeah exactly and you know if we
want to take it to a place that people
can resonate a little bit more
most of us here
in israel we've done different um
service works right we worked at a
restaurant we might have worked in a bar
things like that even small things like
scheduling ships right you need to put
in your availability i was at
mcdonald's exactly exactly so mcdonald's
is a very good example right you have
your shifts the manager needs to occupy
those shifts you need to bring your
availability they need to set up all the
things and there's so much back and
forth usually over texting or over phone
calls and it takes forever and no one
enjoys the experience
and today you can do it with an app a
super simple app you post your
availability you set up the different
schedule does all the movements like the
shift manager publish it to you you get
the notification you have a reminder
before the shift
you need to replace the shift it's super
easy and simple they can approve it they
can deny it so it's very very easy to
manage things and it removes a lot of
the friction makes the operation
more efficient make employees take more
shifts make things just more smooth it
helps the business at the end
fantastic
how is the resistance coming in here
because i mean you're changing some
consumer behavior
i mean it sounds fantastic but i'm sure
then you're you know you're sort of
re-educating a market and you're
retraining sort of how people experience
you know their work so well what are
some of the challenges that are
presented here
um
so mikhail that's actually a very very
good question
um i think it really depends on the time
horizon can things really change over
the past five years and i'll explain
when we first pitched that idea
initially
people should have been very it should
have had a really strong foresight for
the fact that employees would have an
app on their private phones because this
type of organ organization would never
buy company phones they cannot afford it
and that they would actually use those
phones for work related purposes and
five years ago if you had told that to
someone from a vc they would raise an
eyebrow right they would say
i'm not sure that's how things are gonna
unfold
so i think there we saw a lot of
resistance but something super
interesting happened um in terms of the
market i think there's a new generation
now both from an employee's standpoint
and from a manager standpoint because of
facebook because of whatsapp because of
instagram because of all those private
life apps that basically trained us as
people to be able to consume apps in a
very very simple
way people that used to be
non-technological at all so they can
adopt apps as long as they're built the
right way right as long as right serving
the product in the right way it's much
easier to adopt and naturally
smartphones became you know a commodity
internet became a commodity so that type
of barrier went down i don't think we
educated the market i think we had a lot
of luck
in terms of the time to market timing
in the sense that the generation outside
created the demand and i just think
we're at the beginning of the peak i
think we're just now starting to see
people coming in starting to require
that both from the employee standpoint
and from manager's standpoint you know
when you go into a company you cannot
accept it that you need to come into the
office to file and pen and pape a pen
and paper form like your vacation you're
like why isn't it there a form that you
submit and i approve and you know
immediately and i know how many vacation
days you have left and everything it's
like
so but it doesn't make sense for me i
want it to be different and then you go
and you search for that solution i think
that's the audience we're serving today
those people that are just not willing
to accept the way things used to be that
new generation of managers new
generation of employees that bring
things to us so to your question i don't
think we educated the market i think we
were very lucky to be at the right place
at the right time with the right product
and from the market perspective
who is more of the sort of the pushing
force is it the employees is in the
middle of a management who's really
pushing
for this to happen or is it both at the
same time
um so
today it's definitely both i think it
started like with everything you have
the very early adopters it started with
those um usually senior managers could
be even business owners they just want
to be ahead of everyone they want to
beat the competition they want to be
more efficient they want to do things
better they want to do things smarter
and they just wake up one day in the
morning and they're asking themselves
maybe there is a solution out there and
they go in the they search for it but
what we're seeing today is that more and
more managers that used to work with a
tool like that are transitioning to
other places and want to bring it to
like that and that even employees that
were exposed to a tool like that
want to transition and bring a new tool
but it's very interesting to see that i
think over 65 70 of our customers are
actually transitioning from pen and
paper and excel and bulletin boards only
the other 30 are moving from a digital
tool
to our um tool
right so it sounds like you're like
still the long tail was you know it's a
pretty dramatic digitalization shift
right
absolutely i think we're we've seen
about 15
and that's a very rough number right
stick it with a grain of salt but it's
just the beginning of what i expect to
see in terms of booming demand i think
we'll see much more
um in the upcoming years and you can see
it you can see it in google trends you
can see it pretty much everywhere when
you look at the search terms and the the
trends out there sure
so what what becomes possible as a
result of this now so in a new world
where
teams are obviously connected and
and you have this sort of seamless
communication transparency
sort of this middle infrastructure layer
that that allows
people to have to have this
digitalization what what really is
enabled through this in the world around
us
what are different opportunities
so i like to use the analogy of us
office people getting uh
a computer
or an office suit and all of a sudden
you can do all those things right think
about what i did before we met excel
think about
what a lawyer would do before they had
words and track changes and email to
send that between the sites think about
how more cumbersome it was how people
needed to put everything in writing so i
think what becomes possible is for one
um to have everything in real time
and to get real visibility you can close
the loop directly with the front line
super easy if you send the message you
know who read that message if you send
out the task you can follow up on that
house now it's been completed you have a
much better picture when you come to do
planning and operations right so whether
it's payroll which becomes much more
smooth because you have all the
information if there are any gaps you
can easily
process it the scheduling example that
we gave before
to become
extremely more efficient you're becoming
much more proactive as a manager because
instead of trying to do the basics
you're focusing on the next levels of
controlling your organization providing
the different insights and you have
everything in real time which also
allows you to respond much quicker to
different things that you need to do
usually translates to a more efficient
organization a more scalable
organization and a lot of cost savings
now from a go to market perspective
obviously you know you have
such a crazy potential outside with
80 of the workforce in the world but but
still you want to grow quickly how did
you strategize on
was it sort of by verticals
was it by
types of workers how did you decide sort
of how to tackle this growth stage
yeah
um
you're touching all the right points
so i think in the beginning basically
what we were told is that you have to be
vertical specific in order to succeed
but we really objected it because you
know when you have communication
everyone needs communication everyone
use whatsapp doesn't matter which
vertical they are and everyone needs
time tracking doesn't matter which
vertical they are so we really try to
push that all in one experience and not
to focus on a specific vehicle
and it was hard it was hard especially
in the early days
um i think what guides us we're a very
product first type of company what
people like to call plg product growth
which means
first and foremost our product was our
sales person connecting didn't have any
sales for cs people until we had 500
paying customers
actually
no salesperson until i had 500
customers
yeah yeah yeah
um and the way it works for us is that
we iterated a lot with the product and
only when we saw by the way we one of
the smartest moves i think we did we
removed the friction of the pricing as
much as we could we wanted to see that
someone is willing to pay for the
product but we put very low price points
at day one just to ensure that people
are willing to pay for it it's something
that is substantial for them and then we
iterated with the product until it was
mature enough until we got the 500
paying customers mark and from there we
started to scale
and that's when things really started
booming right that's when you start
seeing that hockey stick um behavior
that's when we fundraised and kind of
poured more resources into the equation
and um we did a lot of early days
because it was a very lean startup we
did a lot of organic activity which
turned out super well if you look at
connecting today we are scored
uh we have the higher scores around
pretty much everything we do
um and then at some point once we had
the resources we also started to do the
different activities you would expect
right acquisition channels classic
marketing channels
um different types of partnerships etc
etc
and so how do you sort of as as the
company grows you know now from a little
bit of a from a culture perspective
you're mentioning that a big part of
connecting with sort of sort of this
bootstrapping mentality this organic
growth
product led growth low
low friction to enter let's make sure
that we're providing value and then
actually do the sale
how do you keep that sort of uh
i guess a special commando mentality
also as the team is growing we've raised
like 100 more than 120 million dollars
how do you do that
so
the short answer there is no simple
answer it's a very big challenge but i
think starts and then with the people in
the mentality like you said
uh
we try to live and breed the thing that
guides us
you know we have we call that core
values but you won't see them hanged on
the on the
um on the walls
like it's something that we really try
um
to work hard on a day-to-day basis with
the managers with the new employees with
everyone inside to get into the same
mindset
we don't fall in love with anything
we appreciate change we appreciate
people that love
an environment that ever changes and
know how to grow
in that environment and know how to take
the next challenge
we appreciate builders mentality so
people that can come and take something
from scratch you just sell them
go and open a tik-tok channel and you
know they'll
search it and they'll work day and night
just because they're excited not because
no one told them to and they'll figure
out how to go about it and how to do it
so it really starts with how you
motivate your people how you live by the
things that you say
um and how you build that strong strong
culture
and i know people are often using that
word but at the length of a better term
um
kind of facilitate that strong
capability those muscles that help you
grow and help you deal
you need to accept the fact that things
would break things would change
and you're willing and accepting and
you'll embrace it and you'll build
better out of it and i think if you have
people that share the same mindset then
you can really make big things together
yvonne thank you so much for such an
awesome episode
uh really really
fantastic i love how you're how you've
all identified really quickly that you
know you're there's it's not just about
a fantastic product and fantastic market
it's sort of this combination of the two
coming together and timing is everything
understanding that the world is
transitioning um
understanding that through through sort
of a humble organic mentality you're
able to create real value only once
you've seen this value i can't believe
you've only had sales when you had 500
customers i think that's that's insane
and and that's how startups should be
right i mean create real value
bootstrap be organic
show that you have a real product and a
real need and then hockey stick growth
and and then you're not sort of running
after your own tail you're guiding this
ship and you know where you're heading
and it sounds like all of you have a
really deep conviction about what you're
doing you're understanding the market
you understand the different pain points
that people have it sounds like you were
also surprised sometimes by how large
these pain points were or how
fundamental they were more primitive
than you even thought they would be and
so it sounds that's a just such a cool
story yuval thank you very very much
thank you michael was a pleasure have a
great day
[Music]
you